the US and several of its allies have
repeated their support for Israel while
calling for the protection of civilians
and access to Aid the statement came uh
following discussions between US
President Joe Biden and leaders of
France Germany Italy Canada and the UK
for more on this we're going to go to
Ellen Fischer who joins us in occupied
East Jerusalem and a powerful uh block
of countries there can you tell us a
little bit more about the statement
Ellen well it's an interesting group in
that it is the G7 minus one there is no
Japan involved in this statement and it
would be interesting to find out from
Tokyo why that was the case whether they
opted not to be involved or whether or
not Joe Biden during his day of
diplomacy at the White House on Sunday
opted not to call the Japanese he called
all the leaders mentioned in the
statement as well as Benjamin Netanyahu
from Israel the statement will be
welcomed largely by the Israelis I would
suspect although there's no outright
condemnation of Hamas they do describe
it it as a terrorist group it also talks
about Israel's right to defend itself
although it called for an adherence to
operations within international law this
call coming even though they are aware
that the Israelis have cut power food
and water to Gaza over the last two
weeks even though Aid is now getting in
and also a number of agencies have said
that white phosphorus is being used they
agreed to continue to use their
diplomatic channels uh in parallel to
try and bring an end to what is going on
but what is missing from this statement
is a call for any kind of ceasefire any
kind of humanitarian stop to allow more
Aid to get into the country and of
course there is no call from any of
these six countries for restraint even
though we're seeing the numbers of dead
in Gaza continue to rise day by day in
fact hour by hour indeed Ellen we're
also getting reports that Israel will
potentially postpone its ground invasion
into Gaza what what can you tell us
about
that well this is a report that comes
from the New York Times saying that
Lloyd Austin who is the defense
secretary in the United States has been
putting pressure on the Israelis to
delay any ground war first of all to
allow their additional military assets
to get into the region but also secondly
to allow diplomatic efforts to try and
release the people who are currently
being held as captive you remember that
on Friday two Americans were released
Joe Biden said when he was here last
Wednesday that the Americans are using
all channels all diplomatic efforts to
try and get more people released there
is a feeling that if the ground uh war
starts it will be much more difficult to
try and get any captives uh released
certainly that has been the
view of people here uh across the board
uh what is interesting that on Israeli
Army Radio in the last hour we've seen a
post on social media quoting the deputy
ambassador to the United States from
Israel saying that the United States
fully understands that Israel is at War
and it will decide to do what it wants
to do when it wants to do it so that
would rule out it would seem on the face
of it any Prospect of a delay in the
action but of course as I say any delay
would help facilitate in the Americans
eyes getting more captives out of Gaza
it is a divisive issue we've been
speaking to some Israelis in West
Jerusalem who were certainly mixed on
whether or not there should be some sort
of prisoner exchange with
Hamas it's very hard and very emotional
and our friends are in hostage and we've
been to a few funerals um of our friends
and all our soldiers and friends and my
husband is in the Army so it's very very
complicated um and there's no U certain
answer I think this is a little
complicated it's not simple it's not
either this or that uh it requires a lot
of consideration each side is suffering
we have to think well this is a big
dilemma and there isn't one answer I
totally understand the Dilemma of the
hostages I'm sure I would feel exactly
the same way but to say that this is
what Hamas wants is not correct because
if that's what they wanted then The
Butchery did not have to happen to the
extent that it happened for them to
capture people in order to bargain for
political prisoners
certainly many of the people that I've
been speaking to have been saying that
it was the defense and intelligence
failure that led to these people being
taken captive they would obviously like
to see them released sooner rather than
later and while they blame Hamas for
taking them captive in the first place
they also believe a lot of blame should
be pointed at Benjamin Netanyahu for
those security and intelligence failures
okay thanks so much Ellen that is Ellen
Fisher for us and occupied East
Jerusalem